I don't know if he drinks but he never
has to buy a drink the rest of his life
certainly in this town he Stefon Diggs
the Vikings wide receiver joining us on
behalf of Old Spice red collection of
premium sense including the new captain
designed to help guys everywhere step up
their a scent game without breaking the
bank learn more about the red collection
at Old Spice comm what do people say to
you on the street lately yeah I would
say not coming the game they come up to
me give me a you know a hug or two maybe
a kiss on the cheek really in it thank
you I'm just like okay that could be
awkward there but you're here for
history I mean it that plays history
forever
it was kind of like a weight lifted a
little bit you know um you know with my
team and everything that we went through
to see something good happen you know
adversity I've been there too long but
some adversity has happened what I
quarterback going down in the past years
and you know I'm running about going
down this year it's just like sab
something like that happened is like Oh
something good finally have in force and
you know FL pretty good but do you think
that it might overshadow your career
that you're always known for that
because you had a great game leading up
to that catch I think Yeti catches for a
hundred yards and you've had a you know
consistent couple of seasons
my uh my teammates told me you know we
had we had like a little conversation
like couple of days after like this but
this is as big as it gets for you so you
can't excite me anymore
you doing well so anything now is just
acceptable you're only 24 is it's pretty
early but you know hopefully I can make
it wanted one more play like that and
we'll we'll have something to talk about
take us in the huddle though in all
honesty what you thought
best case scenario we talked in case
after the game about what he thought but
I'm curious you get in the huddle and I
know he says one of you guys is gonna
have to make a play or I'm gonna have
you make a play yeah so we get in how do
I was actually tired cuz we had just ran
to prior nothing like this I'm he just
jogged back let me just jog back so I
get back in the huddle I'm like I was to
play we call it holy calling
he gives us to play and he looks he
looks around you know he gave us like a
little general like I'm gonna give some
money a chance and I'm like I'm I didn't
really initially think it was me but I'm
like just I hope it goes well so I'm
running I'm running I'm running I I get
out of the huddle I line up and then uh
he he throws it to me you know I stopped
I tried to just try to stop and catch
the ball at the highest point in like
gauging to get hit so I can try to get
out of bounds but I just felt like a
whiff Oh next to me and I was like my
initial picture when I turned around and
try to catch the ball was like only one
person was there so if he missed we got
a chance but I'm curious with as a wide
receiver and I saw this with Danny
Amendola when he caught a touchdown pass
in the back of the endzone so that he
you know it's like he took a snap shot
he took a picture looking down to where
he could put his feet down I'm curious
when you catch the ball and then you
come down mentally are you taking a
picture of like what what's around me
you said you felt you know the lift
it's kind of weird because you know as a
football player for the guys I've been
playing for a long time you can kind of
feel the field you can kind of feel
where you are and as a receiver we play
our nose like little like dance and
Liezel and try not to be out of bounds
in toe-tapping I saw that catch and it
was a great catch he kept his feet in so
I would just say mentally you prepare
yourself and you've been doing it for so
long that you know where you are in the
field you know what you need to do so
but you got to catch it first but I
thought you were gonna just catch it and
go out of bounds like in your mind was
that the game plan yes
oh my coach can you imagine if you went
out of bounds [ __ ] everybody shoot up I
says I'm gonna catch it I'm gonna get
out of bounds I'm gonna do whatever I
can to get out of bounds so we're not
caught in any width I kind of had to
gather myself because like you know I'm
thinking let me just go out of bounds
and I like I got it and uh over loud
will kept me up so I was I was happy
about it isn't that that's interesting
that you could have done the smart thing
and got out of bounds in what my people
would criticize
doing the right thing what's uh what
would your teammates call you you have a
nickname
digsy oh well Norville was uh Harwood
I'll see he gave me the name first but
my teammates call me Big Z no returner
mm-hmm dig G ya dig Z it's like kind of
like a child his name I told him stop
calling me if you say don't do it then
they're going to do it exactly so you
gotta kind of like just let it ride oh
hopefully it washes over after a while
diggsy johnny is here
the disappointment though yeah because
you guys now from the outside looking in
it felt like you left a little bit back
here when you got to Philadelphia yeah I
mean I would say mostly yeah you know we
came to play you know we came to play we
did everything that we need to do during
the week but they came to win you know
they were ready to play and everything
that they were doing was working you
know and it's kind of hard for us we had
some turnovers we didn't get the ball
rolling as much as we like to we had a
great first Drive you know you know and
we drove the ball down you know pretty
much like almost every time we had good
movement but we just didn't capitalize
bi turnovers you know all the things my
coach tells us we don't need to happen
if we want to win so who's your
quarterback next year that's a tough
question you know I don't make the I
don't make the big decisions but we'll
see how it goes we got a couple guys
that can play it feels like feels like
Coach Zimmer wants teddy bridgewater
back in that starting line
that's just guy you know but case did
everything to earn the job it's kind of
it's a tough it's a good position to be
in but bad timing right now debt you
know we have guys off and we have so
many good quarterbacks that you got to
make a decision but you know I play with
all of them now you know I would say you
know it's kind of up in air we'll see
where it goes the Commissioner came out
recently to say that you know still
trying to figure out this catch there oh
yeah cats rule
yeah yes do you know what a catch is
like the other definition you know
exactly what's going on the you know
surviving the ground nonsense and
completing the process here what would
be your ideal way of saying this is the
catch rule like what's your definition
it's been so much inconsistency that
you know with Dez Bryant catch and I
think Calvin Johnson yes and it's just
so many so many up and down that I would
just say you know to cover my own behind
and this is it
catch the ball protect it it can't move
and whatever else like you got to do
everything else but it's crazy though
it's very inconsistent less you hand the
ball back to the official I mean that's
really what I would teach every receiver
you catch it and hand the ball to the
umpire or referee the weirdest thing is
you know seeing that the game is you
know kind of how the game is refereed
that they get it from so many different
angles and nowadays if they call it a
catch they need any indisputable
evidence and if they didn't call it a
catch you know kind of like that gray
area I wish it was just something that
this is a catch if you get your hands on
it
it's catch give me build the best built
on your ideal wide receiver hands feet
speed toughness
it's so weird nowadays you know growing
up I wanted to play receiver but I
played a little bit of running back as
well so um your idea for a scout you
know a Calvin Johnson Julio Jones those
bigger guys that you can kind of like if
they're not already great route runners
you can teach them but if they don't
have great hands you can teach them but
for me I was also I was always a fan of
like Steve Smith
you know those smaller guys kind of
similar to me but you know play with a
lot of heart and you can't teach what
they have so I'm more so like I would
say my heart good hands good feet I'm
speed and uh don't give me some names
here like who has the best footwork who
has the best hands who has the most
speed who's throwing up I would say Ted
Johnson hasn't had the best feet you
know really yeah you had the best feet
Bar None you can just hang it up after
that um speed wise he said couple guys
that were fast well in the game right
now yeah guys say oh there was one of
the fastest in the league is he faster
than you here he's probably he's I'm up
there but there's a couple guys that
might be a little hair faster just to
hear too much he's one of the fastest
guys and was I like Julio Jones hands he
has pretty consistent hands and I like
my guy Adam Thielen - he doesn't drop
anything with the yellow gloves you
gotta get you a pair okay those are
performance-enhancing
are we gonna bring up the catcher rule
again cuz but those gloves there I mean
there look at those things
McLovin has a pair you never know Stefan
those are those are a little bit like I
say they're cheating but you know now
they're cheating they did not stick them
you know Dixie I could be your Adam
feeling that nicknames never going
trying to think can we come up with a
nickname for Diggs ESD is special
delivery we go then you get you get
FedEx you get some sponsorships out of
it SD special delivery he's quick on his
feet I like him a lot a lot how about
dig this yeah let's move dig this dig
that none of those things fit like
diggsy right now so we need to work
names are terrible it used to be that
they actually gave somebody a nickname
had nothing to do with their last name
shorting their last name or actually
made you cool then does anybody have a
cool nickname on the Vikings that has
nothing to do with like keenham is but
it would is case closed case
yeah that's not it good that's not good
I mean who who is one that I would know
if you said there nickname I wouldn't be
able to tell you who it was Hey ooh no
you know Zay um you know feelin which is
Nick 89 these oh here we call these hey
no that's not any good I don't know we
don't we're not a nickname team sorry
are you gonna be nice to Eagle fans when
you see him on the street here listen I
didn't know that there was that big of a
rivalry between us you know I'm already
been it for years we played him twice we
haven't beat him but they don't like
this at all so we don't like them I'm
nice to everybody you know I finally
played a middle ground I don't want no
trouble tell us what you're doing with
Old Spice we always enjoy when when
people players come on OC was great last
year is my second time teaming up with
Oh spicy so I'm introducing a new scent
you know
it's called the captain didn't ya Upton
you know that's pretty smooth yeah
that'll be my nickname but it's from the
bread collection you know it's uh but
you have to say name the team captain to
be captain yeah you want to be treated
like a man so there's no spices sure
yeah that's a spicy name all right there
all right so uh any other plug there for
Old Spice just so nobody is obsessed
right so you know who's your captain we
got a company to came take our route off
him you got to get him some captain
holding him when we go to break
can we reenact the catch yeah yeah we'll
do that I teach you guys how to catch
with those good diggsy yes point can I
play the New Orleans defensive back
have you had you talked to him would you
how would that go if you talked to the
defensive end yeah conversations
throughout the game you can imagine you
know where I receive at the DB
conversation absolutely so back and
forth yeah but when that happened I felt
really good I know he felt really bad
but as a person I would I felt kind of
bad I got I just I was happy I was on
the other end of the good side but you
wouldn't reach out to him and just say
hey sorry we're not sorry but honestly
say like you know that it's not a
make-or-break play unison you got a long
career but if you ran it you're about
the same age yes but if you ran into him
here at Super Bowl I was just shaking
his hand like you know I'd give him
someone keep pushing he's Stefon Diggs
dig this or Special Delivery just don't
call him dizzy the red collection at Old
Spice calm if you're watching the look
in will reenact the great catch that
will always be remembered here in
Minnesota for more dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]